it's been said by many people that if
you increase your grip strength you'll
increase every kind of strength so if
you create a strong grip on something it
sends a powerful signal to your central
nervous system that you're in a stable
and secure position and therefore able
to exert force without risking falling
over or dropping something and injuring
yourself this immediately gives you more
force more ability to generate force
because you're holding on to something
better what's more is that having a
stronger grip might even just allow you
to contract your other muscles more
powerfully I heard a really cool example
of this where if you try and tense your
bicep whilst keeping your arm open and
loose your hand open and loose you can't
generate as much force as if you tense
your bicep whilst at the same time
clenching your fists when you contract
any muscle any area at the same time
there's gonna be overspill when you make
a fist as hard as you can it's
impossible not to feel your arms tensing
your back tensing so it seems that just
getting a powerful grip will give you
awesome power in the gym so why is this
well if we look at something called the
homunculus this is an image that was
shown in psychology when we're learning
about the motor cortex this is a kind of
creepy looking figure a horrendous
looking man who has these giant hands
giant tongue giant lips and basically in
this image what those giant features are
doing is demonstrating the proportion of
brain matter that is dedicated to that
part of the body so we can sense things
through our hands in much finer detail
we have much finer motor control in our
hands than we do for instance at the
back of our elbow you can pinch the back
of your elbow you don't even feel it
so you need much larger representations
in the brain in the motor cortex for
your hands than you do for other parts
of your body and it thus follows that
you should spend a decent amount of time
training your hands and your grip and
your grip strength and if you can
strengthen your connection your mind
muscle connection with your grip then
perhaps you'll also be strengthening
your mind muscle connection throughout
your entire body
Daniel's church is
taking him to India to me a man who can
climb anything at lightning speed even
more exciting is a guy called Jyothi Raj
I don't if I'm pronouncing that
correctly he was on Stan Lee's
superhumans and he's called the real
monkey man and the reason for this is
because he can climb like a monkey
apparently observed monkeys climbing and
I wanted to learn to climb like them and
he moves in this incredible inhuman way
he spins around upside down he makes
incredible leap some fantastic dinos and
to the point where it it appears
superhuman so he was inspected by
Stanley's team and they ran some tests
on the way moving they found that his
movements were far more energy efficient
and that he really did move differently
from other people when they asked him
what the secret to this ability was he
said that it was that he trained his
fingers and his grips that's what he
observed in the monkeys the fact that
they had these powerful fingers these
powerful grips and that's what he needed
to train in order to pull off this
superhuman feat and it makes sense as
well that you'd move in a more efficient
way once you know how important your
grip and your fingers are for your
central nervous system they see your
hands Wow
man they're tough as a rock Wow notice
the power is not in the palm hand or
wrist area the technique relies on
focusing my entire strength and body
weight to the tips of my fingers
training forearms is also awesome for
any bodybuilders anyone who wants to
look bigger and stronger because not
only is this one of the only muscle
groups that people can see when you're
clothed so that's awesome if you've got
bulging before I'm sticking out of a
short sleeve shirt but at the same time
it also build up that vascularity if you
use your hands and your forearms more
then you need more blood and oxygen
there and so this is a great way to get
those really veiny forearms just like
Stallone which looks awesome in my
opinion not to everyone's tastes some
people think it's gross but I think it's
awesome so how exactly do you go about
training your grip strength well it
actually comes down to a lot of
different things because it's not just
one muscle of course that's responsible
for your grip it's the action of several
all working together so you have your
forearm flexors and your forearm
extensors so the extensor moves your
hand this way your wrist this way and
the flexor moves it that way and this
also acts on your fingers via tendons
then on top of that you have your
pronator
terry's it's not Teri's it's mine and
your supp inator and that's for twisting
your arm in and out
[Music]
then on top of that you have the
extrinsic muscles of your hand and these
extrinsic muscles
once again include flexors and extensors
and these are what more specifically
move the fingers so there's a whole lot
of different things you need to focus on
if you want to build as much strengthen
your grip and in your forearms as
possible the abductor pollicis longus
meanwhile is the muscle that's used to
move your thumb around and that also
helps you to move your hand from side to
side along with the supper later and the
pronator and then on top of that you
have the brachial radialis and the
OCONUS muscle these are by the elbow
that the top of the forearm and
therefore bending at the elbow back and
forth so yeah there's a lot of different
muscles in the forearms so to start with
let's take a look at how you train your
forearm flexors and extensors which will
not only improve our grip but also
improve the size and the muscularity of
our forearms so one of the few exercises
that people actually do already for
their forearm training is the wrist curl
and you can either do this with a
separated or a pronated grip and all
you're gonna do is hold on to the
dumbbell it should be very light and
then you're going to curl it using just
your wrist so you want to isolate the
movement in the upper arm you can rest
it on a bench where you can rest it on
your knee or just hold it in place and
then just gonna literally move the hand
up and down like so using that light
dumbbell and obviously which way round
you hold the dumbbell in which grip you
use that's going to affect whether
you're training the flexors or the
extensors so you want to do both that's
a kind of boring exercise but it's a
really good one because if you do that
at the start of a workout before say you
do some chin-ups or something then your
forearms feel swollen and pumped and
everything else becomes more difficult
on your grip so that's quite a good way
of doing it or a more fun way of
training your flexors and your extensors
is to do pull-up bar wrist curls and
this is simply hanging from a pull-up
bar and then curling your wrists again
using either an overhand or underhand
grip to train the flexors and the
extensors and then you literally just
curl your own body way up using just
your wrists
awkward it looks kind of strange but you
can do this at the end of a pull-up or
chin up routine and therefore you're not
dedicating tons of time just to your
forearms you're just getting in a little
bit of extra for and work there it's in
general slightly more fun slightly
easier to do than you know going and
finding a really light dumbbell and
sitting somewhere doing this and losing
your pump I find if you want to train
the pronator and the SUP inator then
really any exercise using a twist such
as dumbbell curls with the twist or
Arnold presses we're going from a
neutral grip to an overhand grip with
your shoulder presses of dumbbells we'll
train that twisting motion unfortunately
these methods aren't perfect because the
direction of the gravity the force is
going downwards it's not there's no
resistance against the twisting motion
so if you actually wanted to build that
twisting strength optimally you could
either use a cable and just have that
resist you as you twist your arm in
either direction or you could drive a
nail into a plank of wood this isn't
something I do personally but if you
want to build real twisting power if you
want to optimize for that then this is
something you could do and it does have
some useful real-world benefits all I
can think of really at the moment is
nipple twisting but yeah if you want to
really hurt your friends then get
working on that if you want to train the
brachioradialis and the OCONUS muscle
then apparently hammer curls anything
with a neutral grip tricep kickbacks on
my favourites dumbbell runs will train
those muscles well that's quite a good
one if you get that little bulge by your
elbow
it looks quite cool but of course the
star of the show is going to be the hand
muscles the finger strength that's what
a lot of people really want that
crushing strength and there's lots of
ways you can train this as well of
course so one obvious way is just to
squeeze anything so that could mean
squeezing the dumbbells harder when
you're curling it could mean squeezing
the barbells harder you can likewise
squeeze a tennis ball or pretty much
anything obviously you get these devices
like this the grip trainers and they're
alright obviously anything like this
you're training those extrinsic muscles
in the hand of course one that you might
already know if you watch my video on
all-time strongmen is just to use wider
grip barbell so they're just barbells or
dumbbells with larger bars so you've got
a grip onto it rent it slipping through
your fingers and
it's very difficult to do and if you
don't have a wide barbell or they want
to get one then you can just try
wrapping a towel or something around the
bar and that will make it thicker for
you of course anything is hard to grip
we'll do this well so that could mean
towel pull-ups for instance or it could
mean curling a rope you know on a cable
pulley machine instead of holding onto
the nice handles even just the actual
cable itself gripping onto that climbing
ropes is fantastic for your grip
anything like that will do the job
nicely holding onto weights in general
for long periods of time so that your
muscles don't fatigue but your grip
starts to is another great way to train
your grip this is why farmers walks and
any kind of loaded carry can be
fantastic for your grip so you basically
just pick up a really heavy weight and
walk with it and try not to let it slip
out for your fingers I've talked about
loaded carries on this channel before
they're fantastic for all kinds of
things but they're also really good for
your grip and very similar in terms of
what you're actually doing is a dead
hang so death hang just means hanging
from a pull-up bar and keeping your arms
straight and just seeing how long you
can hold on therefore another way of
doing this is to do the dead hang but
not to use a full closed grip instead
you can use just your fingertips and
that'll train your fingers much more
this is where you need to start being
careful because if you're hanging from
your fingertips it can be a lot of hard
work on your tendons and if you tear
them then you're gonna be out of action
for a long time I need to be very
careful as a freelance writer because my
fingers are my livelihood in rock
climbing there are three different
positions for your hands when you're
doing something like this they are the
open hand where just the tips of your
fingers are holding onto the crag or the
bar there's the half crimp where just
the tops of your fingers are bent and
there's the fulcrum where you've
scrunched up and you're getting as much
purchase on to that grip as you possibly
can
of course holding an open hand grip is
harder than holding a full crimp so you
can work your way up to it that's a
great way of doing progressions like I
say be very careful with this another
way you can do this of course is with a
fingerboard if you're lucky enough to
have one in your gym or in your home
this is just a board that's attached to
a wall likewise you can use the ridge
around the top of your doorframe and if
you're really feeling ambitious you can
try hanging from two fingers from three
fingers I've seen rock climbers you can
do this it's incredible but like I say
please
to it be very careful because yeah you
can really hurt yourself if you're not
careful you wanna tear the tenders on
your fingers
that's nasty and of course any form of
rock climbing is one of the very best
things you can do for you good strength
because you're placing all of your
weight onto your fingers as well as your
legs a little bit but for long periods
of time building up endurance and
strength in your hands and I was a
member of the rock climbing club at my
University and some of the best climbers
there had forearms like Popeye they were
huge and they could just crush things
they had incredible grip strength if you
want to take this one step further than
one of the most awesome names for a
training method that I've heard of is
hyper gravity bouldering so bouldering
is a form of rock climbing where you
don't need a rope and a harness and all
that is climbing shorter distances with
a crash mat underneath so that's a good
way of getting into rock climbing for
grip strength of you don't have the time
or the money to invest in becoming a
proper rock climber but in hypergravity
bouldering you're doing this whilst
adding weights to yourself so that
you're climbing using an even heavier
body weight and of course another way
you could practice something similar
would be to do weighted pull-ups or
weighted dead hangs and sure we can call
that hypergravity training if you want I
definitely want hey Alan what have you
been up to today oh nothing you know
just the usual just hypergravity
training likewise you can also use these
kinds of grips these open hands two
fingers path crimps whilst you're doing
shrugs wants to do farmers walk of
course with a lighter weight but it's
another great way to challenge yourself
you can use this as incidental training
just whilst you're going about your
business carrying lots of shopping for
instance why not carry the bags from two
fingers and train your grip at the same
time likewise there's lots of other
kinds of grips you can use for instance
I talked about the pinch grip when I was
doing my talk on loaded carries and this
basically means you're grabbing two
weight plates or whatever and you pinch
them together with your hands and this
requires you to use a lot of force to
apply a lot of force with your fingers
in order to hold it and carry it or curl
it if you're doing weight plate curls
again there's lots of ways you can
combine your
grip strength training with other kinds
of training just to make sure that
you're getting it in there and another
way to train your fingers of course is
with finger push-ups and this is another
one you need to be very careful with but
this is what gyasi Raj demonstrated when
they asked him how he was able to do
this amazing climbing he'd got on his
hands and feet and started doing just
two finger push-ups or whatever
demonstrating how powerful his fingers
were Bruce Lee of course was famous of
doing two finger push-ups again I can't
do two finger push-ups I don't recommend
you try it you have to build up to it
you can do open hand push-ups on your
just all your fingertips to begin with
and then you can build up by removing
fingers do eight do six take one hand
away another way to build up to it is to
have one hand closed and one hand on
your fingertips if you can't do
fingertip press ups at all to begin with
that's a good progression to use and of
course all of those overcoming isometric
exercises I've talked about in the past
are also fantastic for grip strength so
these are all your things like trying to
rip a rope in half or bend a piece of
steel or rip up frying pan up or a
telephone book anything when you're
trying to push or pull something that
won't budge grip strength and isometrics
go hand in hand no pun intended
very well and not only that but you'll
be building the mind muscle connection
greatly it's great for general central
nervous system training and it'll build
the toughness on your skin you know your
calloused hands that help to improve
your grip because you know your hands
are grippy and also reduce the pain that
you get from doing anything that
involves a lot of grip but all of this
stuff will do that as well doing general
power lifting anything like rack pulls
or I use a hand dynamometer and this not
only allows them to train my grip but
also measure how much force I'm able to
generate and this is something very
interesting because apparently looking
at your grip strength is a very useful
correlate for your general central
nervous system recovery so if you have a
very weak grip in the morning it might
suggest that you have a bad cortisol to
testosterone ratio some athletes and
some trainers will use that as a cue to
say don't train that date you're not
feeding your best you're likely to
injure yourself so this again
demonstrates just how key grip strength
is to overall strength and of course
that's also why it's so important that
you be careful with this do you
introduce this kind of training slowly
because not only is there the risk of a
cue
injury you can also fatigue yourself
overtraining yourself
wear out your nervous system and that's
when you start to see detrimental
effects in other areas of your training
which is not what we want so instead of
doing dead hangs to failure multiple
times in each workout go to 50% 70% at
the end of your regular pull-up workout
like I say maybe once every other week
do wrist curls at the start of your last
training or your biceps training - this
just involve your forearms more try
going up on your fingers the next time
you do press ups etc be gentle with it
be sensible and build it up that way
there you go that's how you build
awesome grip strength awesome big
forearms so that you can climb so that
you can fight so that all of your lifts
become better
if you found this video useful and
interesting then please leave a like
please comment down below let me know
what you think if I've missed anything
out please share it around it helps me
immensely and subscribe to the channel
of course if you want to see more like
this I've got lots more on the way next
week I'm gonna be covering the next part
of my flow States video there's more
videos coming on fitness on bodybuilding
on productivity working online brain
training nootropics all that stuff so if
that sounds good then thanks a ton for
watching and I'll see you next time bye
for now